GDC all of the game developers we're
literally every single one of them not
every one of them because i had
recording sessions last week so our
doppelgangers classic GDC ruse yep and
we chose to be here instead of then
because this is where we wanted to be
yeah one thing the only thing that was
at GDC last week basically though was
virtual reality there was some regular
games but not a VC cowboy running around
at the moment love investment and VR is
you know it's actually coming this here
we got PlayStation 4 hour more fesa
she's snow is all coming out this year
by the way I since I burped I've got
like more burp stuck in because I like
swallowed too much it'll be like the
like a 1-up sound like the opening of
the chest yes did it here's a new sword
there is no nto top no there's none it's
incredible yeah but virtuoso VR virtual
reality it's like playing video games
except like that yeah it's the future so
the one thing that keeps happening to us
on the press side is that like we write
about fear we do videos before your work
and cool trick it's really cool unlike
there is a tendency with the price to be
very interested about the new right
playing so many games or so like we want
like the new thing so it's interesting I
think for me anyway because you have
this on one side you got all these are
really excited people at GDC and press
people and developers all talking about
this thing and then you've got this wet
farsh in the realization of the viewers
and readers which is that like they kind
of get that it's you know perhaps
probably maybe going to be this big
thing but there's this kind of lack of
interest in it because either they don't
have the technology yeah I think that's
what it is okay I don't think it's lack
of interest I think it's lack of
availability because the masses can't
participate in that beautiful thing that
all of the reviewers are experiencing so
you know demo is so essential yeah have
you guys have your dough yeah yeah I'm
at e3 last year um I got to play around
with it which one do you know morpheus
morpheus oh and then the year before
that I also played with um the one over
at Sony all right he's not fair um
but when you got enough I got really
like motion sick I know anything they're
still working it out yeah it was like a
game where you were on a thing and you
were just like rolling down a hill but
yeah he'll roll yeah he'll roll 3.4 yeah
it was it just made me really pukey the
textile I mean that the demo is so
integral to really getting on board with
it I mean I I haven't seen it either and
I've heard rave reviews and that I've
heard some that are a little
underwhelming and then other people say
they get motion sick so I think it's
going to be you know specific to the
person that tries it out but it's so
hard to try and fit people in through a
demo line whether it's a GDC or three or
something like that and I think the
price point also makes people a little
gun-shy I think where it's going to end
up eventually though is that it's not
going to be just games it's going to be
interactive films it's going to be you
know it's like all that stuff and ready
player one like that is the pipe dream
to be able to hop into your favorite get
some point Imam into your favorite
location Walker Anders game yeah those
possibilities I think we'll make it you
know you can't avoid the possibilities
of that kind of tech yeah it's a good
know it's funny that the one demo that
really like sparked my interest about
him warden anything else was one that
actually wasn't really video games
necessarily was the oculus touch one
where you are in a space and there's
somebody else in another room and you're
basically talking to them and like
throwing objects and really the virtual
space was the other person also on me
yeah they were inside in another room
holding whatever things okay that's a
pretty freaking cool yeah and it was
like waving hands like high-fiving in a
virtual space yeah and then after it was
over the gentleman came into the room
and we like we we high-five were
thinking about it because we'd been high
fiving in the virtual space but I've had
you know I met this first book that's
crazy clearly hot and my brain had
decided that I'd met them and I was like
I mean if you can do that across the
world right yeah yeah there was an
oculus demo I think it's so nice Anna
Monica where you put on the headset with
the hand controls whatever they are and
you were inside of a weightless space
station than was floating around either
Saturn or the moon or something like
that so you could look out the windows
and it was fully rendered in 1080p or
something like that frame rate was a
hundred and twenty they said because it
was 60 and 60 and he's in each eye and
he said you would grab onto a part of
the station space station and then push
yourself like through the station and
that's how you navigated everything he
SAT after five or ten minutes he got an
incredibly queasy just because it was
working so well but it became
like second nature so at that source of
that sort of immersion is possible i
think it's incredible it's just I want
to experience that like everybody talks
about it and then you can't do it and it
just makes you jealous and bitter yeah
what's the what's the what's the UM is a
google glass where they showed the
trailer where you could literally put a
TV screen you know you're wearing your
glasses Oh a TV screen on the wall and
you can like this so much drink besides
Microsoft Sam yeah it's not google it's
the microsoft one once that's it yeah
brain farting at the moment sorry
everyone hang on the podcast right we're
smart Oland hololens at the halo at e3
was pretty providing just quite a small
piece but there you are that's something
you've had to go of right yeah you have
that sort of yeah and I was really
impressed by this really cool a small
yeah it's like this but the way they set
it up at e3 you know you were in an
entire environment that had been
decorated and then so your little
picture fit in perfectly with the way
the environment had already been done so
like that multi level of gameplay was
really cool so it's interesting right
because you're you're talking about that
and you're you're almost you're
basically pitching it to me right right
and like what you're saying is you've
never had view are what like you're does
is that like words I did do that one but
like all these people telling you about
it is what yeah and so like is it just a
case to worry like do oculus need to
just put trucks outside of like
universities and just how people yeah it
couldn't hurt I really couldn't hurt
because I mean word of mouth is one
thing but it's it's kind of like giving
a review for a movie that you really
want to see and until you've seen it
reviews are just crap yeah you know you
don't know code totally disagree but
then a film take it only cost like 12
bucks where is the end for this is gonna
cause a horrible yeah so do you think
you'll end up buying wheeler do you
think yeah do you run into you which one
it might be no idea yet no idea I think
that's a decision you have to make as a
couple yeah bro [ __ ] I'm already like
picturing which room in our house is
gonna be committed to it if you haven't
had it as we've something the walls oh
my gosh but there's so many there's so
many things I want to play already i
mean i was recording just this week on a
on a VR game from valve that's releasing
on monday i know they premiered at the
GDC and they said it was it went over
really well and everything and even the
developers we
said they hadn't even got much time like
actually in the game because the the
headsets are so limited right now yeah
yeah it's crazy nice it's gonna be a
long wait before we can do anything yeah
i mean this year's the year where they
all come out but it's probably going to
be another couple years before we have
that like a big mass market like mine
share right i think the race is on I
mean I've heard rumblings that things
are being worked on but who knows how
close they are yeah guess off to wait
and see yeah yeah yeah if you have any
thoughts about what virtual reality
headset you're gonna save up pretty
pennies for and you're watching this on
the Mount please put your comments in
the comment box below will get in there
and have a little chinwag about it loads
of VR stuff I was gonna laugh when
people and when I say chinwag I love
tutelage it makes right it is great I'm
gonna take